so we really got to generate I think
that there's been a tremendous change
over the last century it may be the
biggest social change in thousands of
years of history for thousands of years
you had so many different revolutions
political social and economic so many
different things changed but this basic
patriarchal structure of most human
societies at least the more the bigger
human societies didn't change in over
the last hundred years you see a really
fundamental change in the status of
women and in the relation in general
relations in general it's still very far
from being a completely egalitarian a
society and it's questionable whether it
will be possible ever to have a complete
legal egalitarian society but I wouldn't
say that nothing has been done or
accomplished in the last few decades
knowing to the future and it's also
linked to the other question I'm not
sure those still being genders in fifty
or a hundred 150 years with this new
ability to re-engineer to create bodies
and brains and minds as the basic
products of the 21st century economy the
most fundamental structures of the human
body and mind themselves might change so
I'm not so sure that a hundred years
from now people will have a clear gender
of just one gender just to give an
example of that already starting to
happen in virtual realities for example
it's very easy for a person to adopt a
different gender to change genders or to
construct all kinds of alternative
genders and you have today like kids a
boys who play the roles of girls and
vice versa in as avatars in virtual
worlds today it's still very primitive
you sit in front of the computer and
it's a two-dimensional reality
but in 30 years 50 years more and more
of life might be transferred into a
three-dimensional virtual reality which
provides people with far more excitement
and far more interest than the drab life
in the outside world in an economy where
they're no longer needed and a political
system which we in which they have no
power and in such a situation I mean
it's it's I wouldn't just take it for
granted that the gender structure
familiar to us today and for thousands
of years in the past will still be
relevant in in 50 100 years